من كان يتخيل يوما ان ياتي الى باريس
لاستكشاف انواع العطور او حتى الاستمتاع
بسحر الابنيه والشوارع ليجد نفسه محاصرا
وسط اكوام من القمامه ورائحه كريهه اصحاب
المطاعم والعمال هؤلاء يقومون بازاله
القمامه من امام مطاعمهم لانها اثرت على
اعمالهم بشده بيروت ما كانت هيك يعني
باياماتها ما كان فيها المطاعم يعني ما
بعرف شو بدي اقول
هلا
بدها تيجي تاكل بس
ولكن
اصحاب المطاعم قرروا التحرك بمفردهم على
امل ان تقوم البلديه بازاله اكوام القمامه
هذه العمليه ستتواصل طوال فتره ما بعد
الظهر سنقوم برش ماء الجافيل والتنظيف
بانتظار ان تاتي بلديه باريس وتاخذ كل هذه
القمامه اتمنى ان ينتهي هذا الاضطراب لكن
هذه المبادره لم ترق لبعض السكان الذين
اعتبروا انها لا تحل المشكله بل تقذفها
امام بيوت اناس اخرين لا ذنبلهم بما يحصل
هذا ليس امرا مقبولا ان تقوم المطاعم بنقل
نفاياتها امام ابنيه السكان انا ايضا لدي
قمامه لكن لن اقوم بالقائها امام مباني
الاخرين لاتخلص منها
الاضراب الذي دخل يومه السابع خلف حتى
الان اكثر من 5000 طن من القمامه في باريس
وجعل هذه الاكوام غذاء للقوارض والحشرات
هذا المشهد لن ينتهي قريبا مع استمرار
عمال النظافه باضرابهم ما دفع نائب رئيس
كتله الاكثريه النيابيه في البرلمان الى
التحذير من انه في غضون ايام قليله ستكون
مدينه النور باريس مغطاه بالكامل
بالنفايات فادي الداهوك العربيه باريس